c'est dans cette petite ville sous
contrôle ukrainien à 230 km de mario
paul que les rescapés reprennent leur
souffle
anna savoure ses premiers moments de
calme de soleil avec ses enfants et sa
mère
après 57 jours passés sous terre le
petit yves en un an et demi ne marche
plus tout seul il a constamment besoin
d'être rassuré
on a encore très peur diana dès qu'on
entend un bruit on veut se mettre à
l'abri c'était terrible je ne sais pas
comment on a réussi à endurer tout ça
pour
moi j'ai vécu ma vie j'ai 66 ans nous
dit sa mère mais je pleurais pour eux
pour les enfants je me disais leur vie
va se terminer si vite alors j'ai essayé
d'inventer des jeux pour les réconforter
du pays hôte nuit j'ai toujours beaucoup
sur ces images prises plus tôt par les
sounders ukrainien on voit la bri où
étaient ana ils étaient 30 dans la
noirceur privé de tout
voici où elle vivait dans une pièce
humide son fils est là sous les
couvertures il n'y avait pas de couche
elle en fabriquer avec des bouts de
vêtements et des sacs de plastique comme
illégaux c'était très inconfortable pour
lui dit elle
on voit aussi les militaires leur
distribuer de la nourriture c'est ce qui
leur a permis de survivre cette femme
épuisée avait lancé cet appel à l'aide
natalia réel aussi saine et sauve elle
n'en revient pas encore d'avoir
finalement pu échapper à l'horreur que
vous veniez
on voyait rarement la lumière dit elle
quand on monte les escaliers c'était
trop dangereux on était tout le temps
bombardée et on pouvait se faire tuer
alors on rester en bas à trembler de
peur dans le cauchemar de cette guerre
les rescapés de lusine d'azov stahl ont
eu de la chance en tout cas jusqu'à ce
que la russie en cercle la série parce
qu'ils étaient mieux protégés
qu'ailleurs à mario paul il était dans
les abris les plus résistants les plus
profonds de la ville et c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont été si nombreux à ces
réfugiés
on le voit bien ici construit à l'ère
soviétique ses repères souterrain en
plusieurs étages que tout la plupart des
civils sont les enfants les familles
d'ouvriers de la série
arrivé au tout début du conflit d'autres
sont déclenché des militaires se pousse
tous genres le fils de natalia est
toujours là bas elle pleure en pensant à
lui
mon fils est dans le régiment azoff dit
elle il est resté pour défendre l' usine
d'azov ce talent avec les blessés il ya
encore beaucoup de gens des civils qui
n'ont pas pu être évacués
le mari d'anna est aussi un combattant
elle la revue une dernière fois trois
jours avant son évacuation que nous
faisons au teen trois actions
bien sûr c'est très dur dit m j'espère
que la croix rouge et l'onu vont pouvoir
faire sortir les civils mais les
militaires aussi quand on s'est dit au
revoir qu'on ne pensait pas qu'on ne se
reverrait plus
et l'espère bien sûr qu'ils se
retrouveront pour ses enfants surtout
mais le combat est inégal asos talent
ils sont issus pour les a6 g ne fait
plus beaucoup de doute ici céline
galipeau radio-canada zaporizhya